hello everyone and welcome to a shocking
game from round 7 of the video World
rapid Championship the game uh pretty
much ends before it begins it is Daniel
dubo versus nikal sarin and a lot of you
have been asking in the comments for
quite some time now what is dubo been up
to what's he doing uh well now you will
see what he's doing and uh to make
matters even more intense both Daniel
and nihal went into this round
undefeated
um in all the previous six rounds they
went into into with four and a half
points and a win here would definitely
go a long way but what happened here uh
it's just something you don't see every
day well you see it fairly often when
Daniel dubo is playing other than that
not not very often so here Daniel opens
with D4 we have D5 by nihal C4 and uh
nihal accepts the Queen's Gambit D
captures on C4 we have Knight F3 Knight
to F6 and now Ponte E3 we have Ponte E6
and the bishop captures on C4 so this is
all very standard stuff nothing new here
see if 5 by nihal we have castles and
now Ponte A6 so dubo not worried about
B5 just goes Queen to E2 we have B5 and
now Bishop back to D3 and now C captures
on D4 and again this has all been played
before many many times and the standard
reply here is just e captures and D4 but
the duo throws in a nice Pawn to A4 and
there are uh very very few games that
actually reach this position uh so how
do you how do you play this I haven't
even checked uh at one point does it
become a new game so let me just uh
really quickly check this uh just check
let me check this okay there is a one
here which captures okay seven okay okay
uh uh okay
so here Knight b32 okay so uh uh here
after A4 uh you you have a lot of
options you could Advance the pawn to B
for you could play D captures
um and uh you could play D captures and
E3 although this doesn't give all that
much maybe now you play A4 or maybe now
you want to play B capture as an A4 but
instead we have the immediate B captures
on A4 Rook cap there's an A4 and the
bishop to E7 now again if nihal goes for
this capture it's not a problem just
Bishop captures you could go on a knight
beat the D7 Rook D1 and now Bishop E7 in
New Castle next so this is all perfectly
fine but Nicole went Bishop to E7
without capturing and okay dubo plays
Rook captures on D4 Queen to B6 and now
there is one game where Knight the C3
was played here do both plays Knight B
to D2 and it is now as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game so here
Knight the C6 he attacks dugo's rook and
redouble of course puts the Rook on H4
why wouldn't you yeah there are no good
discoveries so you don't have to worry
about about this for the moment and here
safest for black is just the castle this
is what you should go for however nikal
goes Bishop to B7 It's a Wonderful
diagonal for the bishop but it also
allows do both to just start uh I will
start putting his pieces on more than
optimal squares Knight to C4 now attacks
the queen queen back the C7 and Bishop
to D2 now the bishop is coming to C3 and
the do both has created a bishop pair
from hell we have castles and Bishop to
C3 now you already
have to worry about some ideas like
captures removing the defender of the H6
Pawn then just capturing so nikhail goes
G6 and here duboff plays Knight to G5
and believe it or not this is where the
game ends now it's a very very tricky
position very tactical position the only
move that doesn't put nihal at the the
risk of just losing the game is Pawn to
E5 but it's a very hard to understand
why this is so until you see dubo's next
move here need help played Knight to D5
he says okay once I eliminate the dark
Square Bishop I have nothing to worry
about everything is nicely defended
and even if you go for some capture on
H7 you don't really gain anything like
Rook captures and H7 Knight captures and
C3 already attacks the queen and if B
captures them bishop cappers and G5 so
not much to worry about here even after
some Bishop captures on G6 action okay
you can't capture because the queen
would hang on C7 you don't care you're
just gonna bring the knight in their
game and the game continues however he
missed one very important thing after
Knight 5 Dube of played the Incredible
Queen to H5 that's what dubov played and
he was in this position on move 18 that
nihal sarin resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so quite
a quite a shocking defeat and like I
said both of them went into round seven
without a single loss uh for the moment
in the Fifa World rapid championship and
this is one one tough loss for nihal so
we'll see how he how he continues from
this but a spectacular Victory from
duboff and it is something that we well
not maybe to this extent but it is
something that we've uh already come to
expect when dubo is playing uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it very short one very short video but I
thought I mean yeah I absolutely had to
show this so hope you guys enjoyed it
and you know never never be afraid to
explore any any such option you never
know what it might bring you and okay I
I I I I I guess I don't even have to
tell you what happens if you capture the
Queen Bishop capture some H7 is made in
one and other than that there is no way
to defend against Checkmate you could
try Knight to F6 okay block this but
then you just capture it again you
remove the defender yeah there's no way
to defend if you play something like H6
then we just capture and it's made on
the next move so regardless what you
play you're getting checkmated Queen H5
we can do it once again in super slow
motion there you have it Queen H5 uh
mihal resigns absolutely spectacular
showing by duboff so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it uh I
would like to once again thank Ben
Edwards lar Sullivan groundhapper uh
Jeff grades David Rice Oxley and Kevin
Clark for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of defeated World Championship
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day